il est facile de comprendre pourquoi Edward Teach et ses compagnons
pouvaient être considérés comme des pionniers de la communication moderne,
et en quoi leur symbole de mort...
(Rires)
Ce n'est pas fini !
En quoi leur symbole de mort, le crâne et les tibias croisés,
était un précurseur des logos d'aujourd'hui,
assez semblable aux grandes lettres rouges derrière moi,
mais bien sûr, avec un autre message.
(Rires)
Cependant, le design fut aussi utilisé à des fins plus nobles,
par une conceptrice tout aussi remarquable et improbable,
l'infirmière anglaise du 19ème siècle, Florence Nightingale.
Sa mission était de fournir des soins médicaux convenables à tout le monde.
Nightingale était issue d'une famille anglaise plutôt noble et très riche,
qui fut horrifiée quand elle intégra un hôpital militaire en tant que bénévole,
pendant la guerre de Crimée.
Une fois là-bas, elle réalisa très vite
que plus de patients succombaient à des infections contractées sur place,
dans ces salles immondes et fétides,
qu'à leurs blessures de guerre.
Elle fit donc campagne pour que des cliniques plus saines, claires et aérées
soient conçues et construites.
De retour en Angleterre,
elle lança une autre campagne,
cette fois en faveur des hôpitaux civils,
et exigea que les mêmes principes soient appliqués lors de leur conception.
Ce modèle architectural, qui se nomme salle Nightingale,
a dominé la conception des hôpitaux pendant plusieurs dizaines d'années,
et certains de ces éléments sont toujours utilisés aujourd'hui.
Mais à l'époque,
le design était perçu comme un outil de l'Âge Industriel.
Il avait été formalisé et professionnalisé,
mais restait restreint à des rôles précis,
et généralement utilisé au profit d'objectifs commerciaux,
plutôt que de manière intuitive,
comme l'avaient fait Florence Nightingale, Barbe Noire et Ying Zheng.
À partir du 20ème siècle,
cet ethos commercial était devenu tellement puissant
que tout concepteur qui s'en écartait
prenait le risque d'être pris pour un excentrique, voire un révolutionnaire.
On trouve parmi eux l'un de mes grands héros en matière de design,
le formidable László Moholy-Nagy.
Il s'agit d'un artiste et concepteur hongrois,
qui mena des expériences sur l'impact de la technologie sur la vie quotidienne
si révolutionnaires,
qu'elles continuent à influencer la création des images numériques
que l'on voit sur nos téléphones et écrans d'ordinateur.
Il radicalisa l'École d'Art du Bauhaus dans l'Allemagne des années 20,
ce qui n'empêcha pas certains de ces anciens collègues de le fuir
des années plus tard, alors qu'il luttait pour ouvrir un autre Bauhaus à Chicago.
S'il est vrai que les idées de Moholy étaient toujours osées et incisives,
son approche du design était, elle, trop expérimentale,
tout comme son désir de considérer cette activité
comme un état d'esprit, et non un métier se devant d'évoluer avec son temps.
Malheureusement, ceci était aussi vrai
d'un autre concepteur non-conformiste : Richard Buckminster Fuller.
Lui aussi était un visionnaire et concepteur de génie,
mais également un militant,
entièrement dévoué à la création d'une société durable.
C'était un tel avant-gardiste
qu'il aborda le sujet de l'importance de l'écologie
dans le design dès les années 20.
Malgré ses efforts,
il était bien souvent traité d'excentrique au sein de l'industrie du design,
et il est vrai
qu'il connut certains échecs,
comme, par exemple, la voiture volante qui ne décolla jamais.
Et pourtant, son dôme géodésique,
son plan pour construire un abri d'urgence
à partir de morceaux de bois, de métal, de plastique,
de bouts de branches, de vieilles couvertures, de bâches plastiques,
d'à peu près tout ce que l'on pouvait avoir sous la main,
est l'un des plus grands exploits de l'histoire du design humanitaire,
et a permis de fournir des abris vraiment indispensables
à un très grand nombre de personnes dans des situations désespérées
depuis sa création.
C'est le courage et le brio de créateurs radicaux,
comme Bucky et Moholy,
qui m'ont attirée dans monde du design.
J'ai débuté ma carrière en tant que journaliste et correspondante étrangère.
J'écrivais sur la politique, l'économie et les affaires générales,
et j'aurais pu choisir de me spécialiser dans n'importe lequel de ces domaines.
Mais j'ai choisi le design,
car je crois que c'est l'un des outils les plus puissants à notre disposition
pour améliorer notre qualité de vie.
Merci à vous, chers confrères amateurs de design.
(Applaudissements)
Et bien que j'admire les exploits de designers professionnels,
qui ont été extraordinaires et considérables,
je crois également
que le design bénéficie grandement de l'originalité,
la pensée latérale,
et la ressource de ses rebelles et renégats.
Nous vivons aujourd'hui un moment extraordinaire de l'histoire du design,
un moment où les deux camps semblent peu à peu se rapprocher.
En effet, même les avancées les plus basiques en technologie numérique
leur ont permis de fonctionner de manière de plus en plus indépendante,
au sein, ou non, d'un contexte commercial,
afin de poursuivre des objectifs toujours plus ambitieux et variés.
En théorie,
des plateformes comme le crowdfunding, le cloud computing et les réseaux sociaux,
offrent une plus grande liberté aux concepteurs professionnels,
et davantage de ressources aux amateurs,
et font preuve
d'une meilleure réceptivité à leurs idées.
Certains de mes exemples préférés viennent d'Afrique,
où une nouvelle génération de designers
développe d'incroyables technologies à partir de l'Internet des Objets,
afin d'améliorer les services de santé, comme l'avait rêvé Florence Nightingale,
dans les pays où plus de gens ont accès à un téléphone portable
qu'à l'eau potable.
Arthur Zang est l'un d'entre eux.
Zang est le jeune ingénieur designer camerounais
qui est parvenu, à partir d'une tablette, à créer le Cardiopad,
un appareil mobile de surveillance cardiaque.
Il peut servir à surveiller le cœur de patients vivant en zone rurale, isolée.
Les données sont ensuite envoyées par réseau cellulaire
à des hôpitaux bien équipés, à des centaines de kilomètres,
afin d'être analysées.
Et si des anomalies sont repérées par les spécialistes,
un traitement approprié est alors recommandé.
Bien sûr, cela évite à de nombreux patients
de longs et laborieux voyages, très chers et souvent inutiles,
vers ces hôpitaux,
et augmente significativement les chances
que leur cœur soit correctement examiné.
Arthur Zang a débuté ses travaux sur le Cardiopad il y a huit ans,
lors de sa dernière année à l'université.
Cependant, il n'est parvenu à convaincre aucune source classique
d’investir dans son projet, afin qu'il puisse le mettre en œuvre.
Il a posté l'idée sur Facebook,
où un membre du gouvernement camerounais l'a découverte,
et a réussi à lui obtenir une subvention gouvernementale.
Aujourd'hui, il travaille à la mise au point du Cardiopad,
ainsi que d'autres appareils mobiles, adaptés à d'autres pathologies.
Et il n'est pas le seul ;
beaucoup d'autres designers, aussi innovants que dynamiques,
sont également en train de développer leurs propres, incroyables projets.
Je souhaite conclure en en citant quelques-uns.
L'un d'entre eux se nomme Peek Vision.
Il s'agit là d'un groupe de docteurs et de designers au Kenya,
qui ont développé leur propre application :
un examen des yeux sous forme de kit portatif.
Il y a également Gabriel Maher,
qui développe une nouvelle forme de langage,
pour nous permettre d'exprimer toutes les subtilités de l'identité de genre,
sans avoir recours aux stéréotypes traditionnels.
Tous ces designers, et bien d'autres encore, poursuivent leurs rêves
en tirant profit de leur toute nouvelle liberté,
et ce avec la discipline de designers professionnels,
mais aussi la ressource propre aux rebelles et aux renégats.
Et nous en bénéficierons tous.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)